houston leading the series two games to
one
the sox need to win today to force a
decisive game five tomorrow night
back in houston you see carlos rodon's
last start against cincinnati that was
nearly two weeks ago that fastball
velocity is a key aj because he leans on
it so much he does but he can pitch
without it he proved last week against
cincinnati or his last start excuse me
that he could pitch in 90 miles an hour
he just has to use his other stuff more
effectively jose altuve will climb in
away we go in game four and altuve
aggressive down the left via line and a
fair ball to start the game on the first
pitch
jimenez digs it out and it's a two
bagger on pitch number one altuve takes
third base and there's one down it'll
bring up alex bregman the one two to
bregman swing into this strike 399
on the fastball
not out of the woods yet your don
alvarez the left-handed hitting d-h
there's a one-two
the velocity was there to the bottom of
the first we go bottom of the first game
four of the alds and it's lance
mccullers jr on the mound for the astros
started game one against the white sox
and was outstanding got the win six and
two third shutout innings four hits did
not walk anyone and struck out four in
that ball game one pitch and one out for
mccullers johann monkatta they
switch-hitting third baseman
flips it to the left side and down for a
base hit
he's a board with one away here in the
first yes
the batter
there it is another breaking ball and he
gets grandall to end the inning and
leave two men stranded
an o2 single
to start the houston second now guriel
the first baseman
off the end of the bat popped up
abreu over and he's got it
number one two down
correa still at first and the batter is
jake myers
he swings at the first offering and
flies it out to right good meeting
one down here in the socks second
here's the rookie gavin sheets
oh one hammered in the air deep to
center
that ball is
[Applause]
and myers might be hurt that ball i
think hit the ledge right behind
the barrier and he is down on his back
on the warning track lance mccullers
left the curve ball up and it was
hammered
by sheets
in anticipation of the pitch
that he wanted he didn't miss it the
check is on myers right now from the
training staff
myers gives it everything he has
just short and then he
goes shoulder first into the wall myers
is a natural center fielder with above
average defense that's why he's been in
there as a rookie in the playoffs and it
does look like myers is going to leave
this game garcia the switch hitter
batting from the left side
garcia chases one out of the zone good
pitch from mccullers to get the second
out of the inning his second strikeout
and hernandez is on with two out for tim
anderson 2-2
swing and a mess struck him out on a
slider down and away anderson is retired
third punch out for mccullers who
strands a runner here's altuve he
doubled his last time up first pitch he
saw
a piece
it hit him on the pad but that was not
intentional bregman draws the walk puts
runners on first and second that'll
bring up yard on alvarez a 2-2 again
inside three and two and you could see
rodon's reaction he wanted that one what
an at-bat these last two at bats have
been battles with bregman and alvarez
is down and away and that will load the
bases and correa now is going to get a
crack at it
here's the pitch driven to left field in
the corner that's a base hit altuve
scores they'll send bregman he'll score
correa a two-run double just like that
the astros lead 2-1
how about that on 02. tony larussa out
of the dugout for chicago he's going to
get the baseball second and third in the
batter julie goriel the payoff ground
ball knocked down by abreu
kopeck to the bag he just beat the
runner
kopeck got over there late
nice backhanded pick by abreu
it's gonna go three to one jose with our
defensive play of the game tucker stays
at third one out all right have another
crack at it with maldonado driven up the
middle base hit for maldonado
the astros lead three to one on the line
drive single by martine maldonado
that was a rocket from martine maldonado
he had been old for 12 with five
strikeouts in the series to that point
two men on two outs here's bregman
fastball driven to left center and
that's in the alley
maldonado will score
racing around third base altuve he'll
score
astros up five to one on the double by
breckman i said don't pitch to him
3-0 i don't care what the count is right
there 3-0 you know brengman's going to
be ultra aggressive for the lead-off man
aboard for the white sox here's eloy
jimenez
jimenez on the ground hard hit altuve
correa guriel they do it again a second
double play behind mccullers two men on
it's the ninth place hitter cesar
hernandez so pretty crucial here to get
him before tim anderson comes to the
plate
strike three call got him looking
mccullers freezes hernandez with the
heater and strands two men on the bases
dusty baker is going to pull the colors
as the white sox will come up for the
third time through the order and they'll
face yimi garcia garcia delivers
swinging and a mess got him on a high
fastball a one two three inning for yemi
garcia astros five white sox won aaron
bummer the fifth pitcher for the white
sox today making his third appearance of
the series mccormick at second two outs
michael brantley the batter oh for three
today 1-0 and that's a ground ball base
it into center field for brantley around
third and coming home mccormick he will
score and the astros lead is six to one
michael braley comes through against the
lefty for his first hit of the afternoon
15-game postseason hitting streak now
for michael brantley you see tony
larussa talking with luis robert and
robert is out of this game now as adam
engel takes over for him in center field
you see some of his teammates coming
over to console him you wonder if
there's something wrong with robert
right leg tightness two down it'll bring
up mccormick the center fielder
mccormick goes down swinging they strand
a couple
we've got our seventh inning stretch two
outs runner on first here's stanic for
the astros who leads six to one over the
white sox
slider and that's a grounder up the
middle one hop stab by correa and he'll
step on second
at the same time and it's a force out on
tim anderson duvet in scoring position
on the two base error by anderson here's
brantley rbi single in the six one for
four
chopper back up the middle and another
base hit for brantley
another one to score altuve another huge
add-on run right there two out no one on
for jose abreu
what year was it
well we've talked about this already and
then there and you mentioned it
tony larusa does not like it when you're
throwing up and in abreu has dealt with
this all year was hit in game three as
well although i don't think there was
anything behind that either but
abreu is on the plate
but guys have a tendency to clip them
tom hallian going to graven it's
warnings that have been issued now
and now tony is saying what
he's
really upset
here's how touhey two for four double a
single you scored three times pitched by
hendricks and jose drills it deep to
left field and you can kiss it goodbye
a three-run check for jose altuve
10-1 astros
that's the cherry on top of the ice
cream sundae so garcia is at first and
most importantly for the astros they are
one out away ground ball right side
waiting on el tube he has it from the
outfield grass throws to first and that
is the ball game and that is the
division series for the fifth straight
year the houston astros will play in the
american league championship series as
they defeat the chicago white sox 10-1
michelob ultra organic seltzer as real
as it tastes